I said in my last lecture,
and as you have already,
I'm sure seen Vicky Haughty has,
uh,
two, uh, overarching plot. Uh,
one is the story of the mad you
[inaudible] go and his choir.
Uh, and the story about
the writing of the novel,
the one about the insane don
Quixote will acquire a coherence,
uh,
after the fight with the Caner us.
Jarvis caused it in your translation
because he and his choir will now be
pursued by the holy brotherhood.
I will explain what the Holy Brotherhood
is and by the priest and the barber,
uh,
his neighbors,
the priest and the barber wants to return
along Suki Hanno to his home in that,
uh,
on named village in Lamont Chia,
the episode about the lost manuscript
and the search for the balance of the
story the manuscript found and his
translation follow themes mentioned in the
prologue about the books,
authorship.
You will also have noticed
how, uh, Cervantes, uh,
has a place with the
division of the chapters.
They seem to be arbitrary. Uh,
they seem to be very whimsical.
These are all winks at the reader,
uh,
telling him that this is a very artful,
artificial and fictional
work. Obviously, also,
many of these divisions were made after
the manuscript was, uh, was finished.
Uh, scholars have worked on
this and come to a conclusion,
uh,
in the context of the business,
of finding the manuscript and the
balance of the story and all of that.
Uh, one could ask who is
the second most important,
uh,
character in the Jihad?
Is it Sanctu I think
that it is the narrator,
the narrator and his
various, uh, agents, uh,
who appear, uh, throughout
the novel. Uh, that would be,
uh,
to my mind the second most
important character in the Quixote.
Now, now in the, in this, uh,
playing with the manuscript, uh, and, uh,
the last manuscript and all of that
Serantes is parodying the romances of
chivalry where such
devices, uh, appear, Oh,
this manuscript of this novel was evolved
from where it was written by some,
uh, uh, sage and so forth. Uh,
and Cervantes is parodying that remember
a parody is a marking imitation of the
style of a literary work or works,
uh,
ridiculing,
is stylistic practices
by exaggerated mimicry.
In that sense,
a parody is both a criticism and an homage
because it is a copy of something you
said distorted copy,
but it is still a copy.
Uh,
so the business of the unfinished
manuscript and it's translation,
uh,
rekindles questions and issues that
the narrator opened in the prologue,
that product that we discussed
a number of classes a ago.
Uh,
I will talk a little bit today about
why all of these games of authorship,
but that does sort of recapitulate how
many texts are virtual texts we have so
far.
We have the original texts that were
supposedly written in Arabic by allying
moreish historian called see there.
I met, they've been in Haley.
Um,
the second is that text,
uh, of the translation
that the narrator pays for.
Then if further text is the one
that this narrator presumably,
uh, corrects and, and, and,
and copies and rewrites and
comments upon them, their margins,
as you will see in several
episodes in, uh, in the future.
Uh, but what about the
manuscript up to chapter eight?
And that narrator,
uh,
we have no idea how the narrator
came about that manuscript so that,
uh, uh, uh, the texts of the
first eight chapters, we don't,
it is not explained, uh, uh, where
it came from. Now, this whole,
uh,
collection of manuscripts do
not make a coherent system.
Uh, you can reduce it to a coherent
system. Just we have the first one,
the second one, the third one. It is all,
it all remains a vague Ann
and Ann Anne and mystery.
And besides, uh, we know
that the whole thing is a,
a joke beginning with the name. See
the I made, they've been in Haley,
uh, or bedding. Hannah,
what's bedding? Hannah
eggplant or say I that is his
last name is could be eggplant.
So it is a joke. Um, no,
why I Cervantes and his narrate or
establishing this distance from their own
text.
How does this distancing Mesh
with the authorial willfulness?
We found in that first sentence
when the narrator says,
[inaudible] the name of which I purposely
omit referring to the village in La
Mantra where Don Quixote
or Alonzo Kiano, uh, lives.
It is as if this modern
author said Avantis could not
pass it his own existence.
We thought radical reservations,
self doubts.
Uh,
sometimes it's about himself as a creator.
I have emphasized that this kind of
ironic distancing a has echoes of Montañas
self deprecate Tori, uh, irony. Uh, also,
uh, uh, echoes of Erasmus is a irony.
I have only mentioned Erasmus in passing
the great humanist Erasmus of Rotterdam
who had many followers in Spain and
who wrote a book that may be one of the
sources of the cohort.
They called in praise of folly,
in praise of folly. It's a
very, very ironic a book.
They start praising folly.
It is doing so in a mocking way,
uh, but it is not sort of
mocking way that you find in, uh,
in, in, in Cervantes. Now, uh,
it is as if a set of anthis we're
removing the origin of the texts.
We're leaving it, uh, in
a, in a, in a sort of a, a,
a cloud of mystery.
And that this is part both
of the irony and of the, uh,
joke. Remember the quote
from Luke Acts that I, uh,
read in the first lecture
about this first modern novel,
uh,
emerging at a time when the Christian
God has abandoned the world.
You do not have the centeredness
that you had in the divine comedy.
If you have read Dante
in the divine comedy,
everything coheres because there
is a cosmological system, uh,
on a, uh, with the attendance
symbolism provided by,
by the Catholic Church,
by Catholic doctrine. Uh,
I'm so the self of Dante, the
pilgrim, uh, is very much,
even though he's also like
don't be halted traveling,
uh, within a coherent
universe. And in fact,
in the very middle of the divine comedy,
the centered verse,
the Central Verse of the
divine comedy alludes to Dante.
So Dante is at the center
of this coherent universe.
This is not the case in the Quixote.
And these are for your games, uh,
underscore that this is
no longer the case. Uh,
remember that this is,
as I've been saying,
a post Kapernick and world,
a world in which the earth is no
longer at the center. Therefore, man,
quote unquote, mankind is no
longer at, uh, at the center.
So, uh, uh, this is what is, uh,
at stake as we were in all
of these other games. Again,
these are very serious issues, but
Servon is always presents them, uh,
uh,
in a light humorous tone,
which is part of the irony
itself, the, the humor,
the laughing at oneself, uh, and
the laughing at others. So this is,
uh, uh, uh, uh, very important,
uh, element of, of, uh,
of the Quixote,
uh,
and one that it has in common with a
very famous painting by Diego Velasquez,
Diego Velasquez, the Great Velazquez
about whom most of you, most of,
uh, most of heard, um, and that painting,
Oh, uh, it's not very well represented.
It's kind of blurry is last.
Meninas they made the maidens of honor.
Um,
can we improve a little bit on
the quality of that? Maybe if we,
if we turn off the lights.
Okay.
No, these are like, well that'll help too.
Is that a focus?
Is it better now? It's better, but it
sort of, what could it be improved at all
here? So lends up,
oh, what is wild there? We can't do
anything with it. Got me. So I have, um,
I have brought both my pointer
and a, if you will, excuse me,
this little flashlight so I can look
at my notes. A hoop he doesn't, uh,
it's not distracting to you. Uh, as
I have a perhaps mentioned before,
I am a pilot and this is
my, my pilots, a flashlight.
Do you use it in the
cabin and the cockpit?
I'd make to look at charts
and stuff like that.
And I thought that I could
improvise and use it for this.
So now as you look at the painting and
I apologize for the poor technology,
uh, and uh, I, uh, promise that we
will bring a better one the next time.
Or maybe I'll make a copy of that.
I can distribute, first of all,
as you look at it,
think of what I mentioned before
about Albert is the pick Tuta uh,
the, uh, treaties on perspective.
Remember that I talked about Leon,
I'll Alberti Leon Battista Alberti 14,
oh four, 14, 72 and Italian, uh,
who wrote these treaties on perspective.
He was an architect and
wrote an architecture and I
really encourage you to read
this little tree. It's very brief,
but it's very influential, uh,
because he, uh, he, he, uh,
he laid down the basis for perspective
in, in painting. As you can see,
we do have perspective here because of
the relative size of the figures as they
move away from the front.
So I just want you to take
that into account. Uh,
now the, the, the relevance
of Las Meninas working hard,
they're essentially,
uh,
because of this issue of self
reflexive putty in both works,
that creator has been given a prominent
place within the work and in both AFP or
in their function as creators
of the very work in question.
That is bill [inaudible] and he is
obviously in the act of painting.
I said,
Vantis appears within the whole day
in the act of writing the novel.
Uh, now, uh, we look at Velasquez,
he looks a little quizzical.
We will speak a little bit
more about his figure. Uh,
and you can,
uh,
recall the words I've
said this in the prologue.
When he wrote,
I often took pen in hand
and as often laid it down,
not knowing what to say.
And once upon a time being in deep
suspense with the paper before me,
that pen behind my ear,
my elbow on the table and my cheek on
my hand thinking what I should say.
And you can think of
Velasquez, uh, poised in the,
in a similar way,
uh,
as if thinking of what to paint next.
And also actually comparing,
uh,
he's models who are speak about who
the models are to what he is painting.
But it's the same, uh,
moment, uh, uh, of, uh,
of of doubt that we have in,
in, in, in, in, in, in, uh,
uh, instead Avantis. It is
kind of a visual aporia.
Aporia is a rhetorical
figure to express doubt. Uh,
a p o r I a, uh, and a,
a visual Aporia and that,
uh,
Belasco seems to be hesitating
what the next brush stroke will be.
Now,
uh,
less money now seems to capture a moment
and not a very significant moment.
And that is significant in itself.
How do we know that it's not a
very significant moment? Well,
there are certain gestures like this,
a little girl,
I just put her foot on the dog.
Uh, these figures back here,
if we could see them more clearly,
you can see they're engaged in
a trivial conversation. Uh, uh,
the, the, the, the
princess is being offered,
I think a glass of water or something by,
by this made and this man on in the back,
uh,
is about to leave the room.
So it's an insignificant
moment. There's a moment, uh,
uh, like those inductee Horton, those
many moments that are contingent,
serendipitous, uh, things
just happened. Uh, not,
uh, in a sequence, but just caught
like a snapshot. And that is what,
uh, uh, is important about this, uh, uh,
moment in which, uh, uh,
Velasquez on his, uh,
uh, all of these other people
are in the painting are, uh,
are caught up now of the painting.
We see only the back of the painting
and we see the Easel, the pains,
uh, the brush that he's received,
the instruments to create the painting.
And in fact,
we are in Velasquez Studio,
his workshop.
So Velasquez is painting the inside of
the workshop within which the work of art
is being created
as we are,
as we read about the manuscript
being copied, translated
and so forth. Given the,
the, the, the,
the details about the composition and
the creation of the novel that we are,
uh, are reading this, this studio of,
of Velasquez would be akin
to Don Quixote's is library
where he keeps the books
of from which I, uh, he has, uh, uh, uh,
that have turned him, uh, Matt.
Now the other important element,
perhaps the most is that the,
the line between reality and fiction
between life and art has been abolished.
How saw, well, uh, who is
the model of the painting?
Well,
presumably the king and Queen who are
reflected on the back on that mirror.
But the models are truly ourselves as
we position ourselves in front of the
painting.
In fact,
the first time I saw this painting
many years ago in 1969 to be exact,
uh, it was, now it's in a large room and
you can barely get to see the painting.
There are so many, uh, uh, uh, tourists.
We're looking at it and guides
talking about it and so forth.
But when I saw it in 1969 and the
problem is museum, it was in a room.
The painting is a much larger than what
you see here. It was in a room, uh,
that, uh, for itself. And, uh,
the dimensions of the room and the way
that the painting was, was, uh, uh,
position. The moment you walked
in, you walked into the painting,
you became the model.
Uh,
it was really a uncanny
sensation that you had.
And we really had the sense that you
had walked into a painting and you had
become the painters model.
You have to become that which he was
in the process of, of, of painting.
Um, so, uh, here we are,
become the model as there is a Belasco
is within his own painting. He was,
he was a genius, vain, a little lacy, uh,
both boastful. He's wearing the, the cross
I think is of Calatrava, one of the, uh,
military orders. You didn't become
a member of the Calatrava or just,
uh, like that. So He's been boastful. Uh,
and there he is. Uh, uh, now
all of the, all of these self reflexive
moves that we've seen in the heart,
they are the same.
Uh,
here we see the painting. I see where, uh,
from behind we, we, we see the
preparation of the painting,
but not the painting itself.
My late friend,
several sort of Dewey said that the
Las Meninas was within [inaudible],
but backwards the same way that in
the Arabic manuscript of the Quixote,
presumably that Quixote is backwards
because of course you write Arabic the
other way. It's a little bit
too clever perhaps, but you, uh,
you get the idea that the
painting is within the painting,
but you're not seeing the painting.
But how the painting is comes about.
We also have the issue of,
uh,
the multiple perspectives.
None of,
none of them complete. That
is, uh, Velasquez can see us,
can see the model. He can't
see the rest, the rest of the,
of the, uh, of his studio.
Uh, the, uh,
the mind in the back is the one
with the most complete view of the,
because he can see the painting and he
can see the models even deed the models
are the king and queen.
So ironically it is not man.
Who is it at that point?
Uh,
who has the most complete view?
I say ironically because I detect a
pun on the Alaska says a park in that a
figure, uh, uh,
because that in terms of
perspective is more or less,
but the plant, the fleet in
French, the vanishing point,
the boom to the food guy in Spanish.
That is the point of the center
and the depth, the depth of the,
uh,
that is the vanishing point.
And ironically in that pump to the full
guys in man about to leave various,
I think the punt involved there,
or perhaps I am being just too
clever like my friend, I said,
but the idea is that no one
has a complete perspective.
Everything. Everybody has a
partial incomplete perspective,
including the artist.
And this is a fundamental,
uh,
because it makes for this,
uh, Ironic, incomplete view.
Uh, remember, uh, the greatest, uh,
part of the irony in Cervantes is that
we only have a partial view of this
infinite world.
Uh,
this post Kapernick and now Galileo world,
we're going to live who wrote
around at the same time.
And Galileo discovered the
use of the tennis coach.
He discovered the infinite spaces.
So our perspective is always limited.
So,
so in the Meninas,
the perspectives are all limited partial.
And in that to,
uh,
the painting on the novel are alike.
Now, Galileo, I think I quoted
him in an earlier lecture. If not,
I'll call him again. And
I said, the more we know,
the less we know because he was
just covering more stars, uh,
more space on.
He knew then that it would be
impossible to get to know all of space.
We're still in that situation,
although we have improved
our capacity now.
So. So what, so what
is the significance of,
of all this? Uh, what I've
just said, I mean the, the,
the limits of human knowledge,
the limits of self knowledge, uh,
uh, and, uh, what else?
We are the models. We are the
models of the painting. And,
uh,
Ben last case has given
himself a prominent position
in a painting that should
be the painting of the king and Queen.
So he has usurped the place
of the king and Queen.
He has given himself a
more prominent position.
He has as well as were erased them to
put himself, uh, this is this ambivalent,
uh, uh, uh, position of
the, of the modern, uh,
I writer and uh, or, or, or, or author or,
or painter or artist,
uh,
about his own creative
powers. But you know, he is,
uh,
he has put himself in the painting
instead of those who should be the models
that came.
And furthermore,
he has opened the space of the model
so that we as we see the painting,
uh,
actually occupy the position
of the king and Queen.
This has all kinds of political
implications. You see,
the king and Queen had been removed and
we who are commoners can occupy instead
that position. So in that sense, this
is a very revolutionary painting.
This painting is saying,
anybody can be king and queen by you're
stepping in front of my painting,
I'm becoming my model. You will
become king and queen for that moment.
Remember there was a show
called Queen for a day.
You'll become queen for a day
or a king for a day. Uh, uh,
you understand?
So there has been a
displacement of power here,
uh, in, in, in, in Velasquez,
this painting by omitting the king and
Queen or by relegating them to the back,
uh,
to a reflection.
They're very kind of a blurry reflection,
made more blurry by our poor
company here, uh, uh, of the king.
And Queen. So now, historically,
if you will read your earlier,
you will see that this reflects a
real political situation in Spain,
meaning that in fact,
the power of the monarchy
has been diminished in this
painting is from 60 1656
remap Mary's later than Vicky hotter.
But history did move
that fast in the period.
So you can 1605 Persky
halter 60, 56, 50 years ago,
give or take. But by the 17th century,
the Spanish monarchy has been weakened.
Uh, it is in the, in the, uh,
in in the hands of a
valley. Those, uh, uh, uh,
nobleman occupied positions
of power and, and, and, and,
and the Habsburgs were, uh, uh, very, uh,
uh, this interested
in, uh, in, in, in, in,
in governance and more in,
in luxury and all of that.
But Alaska is painted, uh, the
Habsburgs in some of those activities,
hunting and stuff like that.
But here in this painting,
he has eliminated them
from the position of power.
He has placed himself at the center and
it has allowed US commoners to occupy
that position.
So this insignificance
of now that the panel,
the most important parallels to,
to this will come in
part two of the Quixote.
Uh,
but I have,
but I will anticipated here when sank
[inaudible] he's made governor of a mark,
uh, Highland, uh, uh, on, on, on central,
uh, by the way it performs
well as a ruler. So he,
the commoner has come to occupy
it post deposition of Mueller.
And this is something something similar
to what is happening here in Las
Meninas. So this is why
this painting is so, uh,
important, uh, uh, uh, in
relation to the Quixote.
But I also want you to,
in anticipation a look
at this figure here.
Uh, the, uh, the kings of Spain.
Like many others,
including Astec emperors,
kept,
uh,
freaks in their court for entertainment
and for amusement midgets,
people deformed and all of that. Of
course, this is from our perspective,
horrendous. But it was part,
uh, it was practiced all over.
And Bill,
last case was fascinated by
people who had a peculiar,
uh, features, uh, irregular
features. Uh, he painted, uh,
midgets and, and, and so forth.
And, uh, this is obviously a,
a deformed,
a woman.
I think that she is important,
uh,
because Cervantes too was very much
interested in depicting a strange
individuals, individuals who
are, are, are not beautiful,
but who have been scarred by time,
uh,
on by life, uh, and by, uh,
bad luck and so forth.
So when you get to the chapter in the inn
and you read the descriptions of Marty
tornness, the, uh, when she a prostitute,
uh, who creates that whole
fracas, uh, at night in the,
in think of this, uh, of
the face of this, uh, uh,
uh, figure here, flat faced,
deformed and so forth because it's
another correspondence are very important.
Correspondence between the Alaska says
aesthetics and Sylvana stasis aesthetics.
So, uh, so much for now for Las Meninas,
we will go back to Alaska is later, uh,
quite soon as a matter of fact to look,
uh, at, uh, another one of his
masterpieces. But for now, uh,
so much for last many,
now we will go back to having light.
Okay.
Both artificial and a
little bit of natural light.
Oops.
The one thing that I
failed to mention is that as you
noticed in looking at the painting,
Velasquez has given himself unimportant
position within the painting,
but he's not a central position.
He Easy Nano bleak position
as it were a lateral position.
Uh,
this emphasizes this ambiguity of the
power of creation of the modern author.
And at the same time, the self
doubt to self doubt, uh, that, uh,
that, uh, the cell terrific
reflectivity, uh, expresses,
uh, so it is, it is, I think,
noteworthy that he is on,
on the side. I said we're, and
the creator is looking, Eh,
obliquely at the, uh, uh,
of the, uh, the model,
um,
in the same way that said,
Vantis says that he is father
or stepfather of his work.
Remember what he said in the 1605,
uh,
prologue that you, that we talked
about in one of the first classes,
the bleakness of,
uh,
of Alaska says position within
the painting is similar to that.
We'll bleakness of whether he's
father and stepfather on so forth. So,
uh, we, uh, go back now,
uh, uh, do the Quixote.
Now after the episode with the scanner,
the Wask, uh, when, uh, uh,
Don Quixote, uh, dangerous.
This man in this, in this fight, uh, uh,
central is a very apprehensive.
He is sure that they're now going to
be pursued by the holy brotherhood.
Uh, the, uh, they don't get held down.
Sangio moving a whirl of alienation of
madness on social ability on how cancer
society deal with donkey
halt. This is madness, uh,
real society.
Uh,
now this issue is highlighted
by the presence of civil law.
Uh,
indeed in the book central knows that
they're being pursued by the center man,
Dad, and who was the same tire
man, dad or wholly brotherhood.
This was a vigilante police force
that the Catholic kings had created.
Ferdinand and Isabella, you
remember your Elliot, uh,
y remember that their greatest,
uh,
they invested a lot of effort in
trying to unify the Spanish peninsula.
But as I've mentioned,
Spain is divided in several regions with
different cultures and languages and
exemptions from the law.
Uh, where royal authority,
just like the federal law in this
country could not reach because of those
assumptions that this, uh,
that this regions had. Uh,
therefore the Catholic kings created
a police that could go through those
regional boundaries and
apprehend fugitives.
The Holy Brotherhood was in charge of the
roads because the roads were under the
purview of the, uh, of the crown. Uh,
and,
uh,
they were parallel to another institution
that the Catholic kings created.
That was also, uh, uh, they're
also, uh, could, could,
could, uh, police, uh, uh, all of the
pinion. So like the holy inquisition,
the acquisition code, police,
uh, regions other than Castille,
that is Galicia, the bass
countries, uh, and so forth.
And so could the holy Brotherhood,
the Holy Brotherhood were feared because
they could, uh, not only apprehend you,
but, uh, try you and execute
you on the spot. And,
uh, Sanchez that he already hears
their arrows buzzing in his ears.
Why? Because sanctuary is
vulnerable to the holy brotherhood.
Where asked Don Quixote,
I send Evalgo feels that he
is protected from the law.
But so sanctuary is a one,
if you will notice who insists that
they are being pursued by the holy
brotherhood and that they have a,
they have to, uh, to hide in the,
in the hills and, and, and so forth. Uh,
the Holy Brotherhood,
I sorry to give away the plot
will eventually apprehend them,
but let them go at the end
of perk of part one. Um,
now the,
the members of the Bra Holly Brotherhood
were just ordinary people who were, uh,
engaged in this, uh, uh,
in this police force.
So
we moved out to the adventure with
the goat hurts, uh, and the speech on,
on, on, on the golden age.
That is one of the more famous
episodes of part one. Uh,
now this is an episode like others in
which a contrast is established between
what Don Quixote has in his head
from having read so many books and,
uh,
the real world around him.
He thinks that these goat hurts are
like shepherds of the classical,
uh, tradition. And this is what
makes him think of the Golden Age.
When there is no mine or Lao,
there is no private property,
there is only a goodness and
man lifts are one with nature.
And he delivers his beautiful speech,
which is filled with all kinds of cliches
from the classical tradition to this
quarter. So don't understand
what he is talking about at all.
But he, uh, what, what is the, uh,
what is the,
the connecting thread between
that idealized reality?
Uh,
he said that idealized world donkey,
his head and the reality of
this goat hertz who are, uh,
uh, listening to this speech and
not understanding a thing. Uh,
that donkey hope is it say the
one thing that connects the two,
and it goes back to one of the points
that I've made before is the goat herds.
Kindness.
They are kind,
that is that which has not
changed from those classical,
idealized times.
And the present is the kindness of people.
And remember that I said that
I serantes likes to depict, uh,
people from the lowest classes,
uh, being, uh, kind of, uh,
to each other and to Don Quixote.
They have not reacted to
Doki Quixote's appearance,
which is striking to say the least,
uh,
for this man to suddenly show up,
dressed in armor,
on speaking this way. And they have
allowed him to, uh, to sit with them,
to share their food and
their drink. And, uh, and uh,
do we involve in their, in their life. So,
so there is a sharp contrast,
but also a commonality here.
The, the people, the
goat hurts or kind, uh,
to Don Quixote and allow him to be,
uh,
what he wants even if they
don't understand what it is
that he is talking about.
Uh,
now this is the first of several post
prandial speeches in the Quixote.
This is the word, the, another one
of these words that I'm going to,
to teach you in this class so that you
can be very pedantic Yalies in the,
in the present and in the future.
Postprandial simply means, uh,
an after dinner speech. Uh, so,
uh,
what is the significance of
this postprandial speeches
on what do they have to
do with the theme of
Donkey Hotez, uh, speech?
Well after dinner speeches,
celebrate the defeat of the,
of the world that is of animals
and plants at the end of work.
And there haven't been turned
plants and animals into food. Uh,
here, uh, the, the eating some
meat, they eat, drinking some wine,
which is like the blood of the earth.
They're passing the,
the wine around and they are, uh, uh,
enjoying the fruits of their labor.
At the end of the day,
they're celebrated the
end of work and rest. Um,
and there is a connection of course,
between the eating and the
talking and the speech, uh,
oral activities, uh, both of
pleasurable activities. Uh,
so this is the connection between
this postprandial speeches,
between the food and the under speaking.
Uh,
others will be a, there will be
much more Merriman and so forth,
but this is, uh, a, a,
a recurring scene in the,
uh, in, in the Quixote.
Um, there is a great deal
about food in Don Quixote. Uh,
and in some cases,
food and language actually coalesce,
uh, most, uh, memorably.
And,
uh,
when don Quixote on central vomit
on each other after the episode of,
of the sheep, uh, when they vomit
on each other and it is a sin,
I see food and language had become
one and they have a dialogue,
uh, between them. I vomited on you and
you want me to me. And that is a form of,
of dialogue.
I know it's not a
very palatable to think about that,
especially if you just had lunch.
But this is a, uh, this is the,
the significance here of
speech on food and uh,
okay. And so, but the most
significant part of course is the,
it's this is the contrast
between Doki halters, uh, uh,
ideas and cliches about drawn from
the classical tradition and the real,
uh, everyday, uh, life of
this goat hertz who also,
uh, serve as a transition toward, uh,
the Monticello. Marcel Langley Saastr
my episode in which the whole, uh,
uh, theme of the pastoral, we'll be,
uh, we'll be, uh, taken
up, uh, out of, out of,
we could say a higher literary level.
The stakes are much higher and that
you saw stonewall and Marcella episode
because of course the death
has occurred. Uh, and uh,
there is a real, uh, a conflict.
But so I think that the
transition here is smoothed.
The transition is made smoother by
the figure of evolve who you have.
I'm sure you remember,
uh,
who was the man with whom donkey hall
to engage us in conversation about the
nature of, uh, of, uh, of
knighthood and, and, and so forth.
And they all anticipate because it had
been told by the goat hurts and so forth
about this conflict involving the
death of, uh, of the disaster.
Most have really soft Domo.
So we move to that
episode in which the main
theme appears to be that of freewill.
The theme of Freewill,
uh, is the main thing,
but an attendant and very
important theme is also that again,
of literature, literature
and its effects. Because, uh,
Marcella and resource are,
uh,
figures that are counterparts to
donkey hottie in their relationship to
literature because both
Marcel angry source to more,
but mostly Marcella want to
play act and a literary role.
She wants to be a shepherdess,
uh, and take to, uh, to the hills.
And of course resource Domo,
uh,
does the same to pursue her,
uh, but also resource Domo.
Uh, and in this he is also, uh,
like Don Quixote is a reader
and not only a reader,
he's a student from the University
of Salamanca and a former student,
the graduate and a port.
So the stakes here,
as I say, I repeat, are much higher.
And it is almost as if
literature where on, uh,
on on trial we can remember what the
scene is consistent [inaudible] has
committed suicide. It is not said, uh,
straight forwardly because
suicide is mortal sin.
And, and, and Savannah,
this is writing in within the context
of very Catholic Spain and he can't just
ride it out directly that
we source the more, uh,
committed suicide.
But the words used in the text
desperado he became desperate.
He was desperate all point out to
the fact that he committed suicide.
He committed suicide because
Marcella spurned him.
Uh,
but what is amazing here is the very
detailed socioeconomic context of the
episode.
In this sense,
it's Mantis is anticipating ballsack the
great 19th century French novelist who
gave very,
very specific details about the
economic situation of his characters.
And here we have that because we learned
that Marcella Marcella is very rich.
She has achieved the daughter of William,
the rich who uh,
her mother died giving birth to
her and then William the rich,
died and left Marcella, uh, uh,
and trusted to an uncle, to a brother,
I guess of his who's a priest.
Uh,
and who,
who will administer Harris
date until she gets married.
Women could not a whole property outright
on the moment that you married the,
uh, state would go Ooh,
would pass over to her, uh,
husband in the case of the resource to
who is no longer a youth as we will meet
later in the book. He's already 30 years
old when he dies because when Gwen said,
when lucky haughty leans over
to look at the cadaver, he says,
I saw a man of about 30.
Uh,
risotto is also, uh, uh, rich.
He has inherited a great deal of,
uh,
of property in lands and animals and,
and so forth.
Uh,
and uh,
so it seems as if this
were a perfect match.
He is of noble, uh, lineage. She's not a,
but this would not be an impediment
and, uh, it would not bring down the,
uh, the Linus said, where
because a nobility is,
was passed on in the Castilian
laws by through the mail.
So it said renters or created
a situation here for a, a,
a perfect marriage in a small
village, uh, this to rich,
a young people would marry
and, uh, create a larger,
even a state. It could become
even a my, your ass go.
It worked that you will learn,
uh, uh, about a little more
later and entailed state. Uh, and, and so,
uh,
now what intervenes when intervenes
is Marcella has a desires to become a
shepherd to spurn all of her many suitors.
Uh,
Andy Resource, Tomas,
uh, mad pursuit of her.
You saw stonewall is a, a,
um,
a port.
We learn that because his
poem is read at the funeral.
A typical Petrarchan concerning,
uh,
he's also the one who writes the outdoors,
Sacramento Talis,
the allegorical place on
Corpus Christi Day. Uh,
so he does a religious play,
relates about the Eucharist. Uh,
he said costs mammographer he can tell
what the weather is going to be or the
future and all of that. He
said, kind of a budding Faust,
uh,
good to Faust in the 19th century in that,
in that he can, he wants to foretell
the future. He's madly in love.
He supported,
he has all of these qualities,
all of these sort of demonic
qualities that lead him, uh,
to desperation and to a suicide.
In fact, uh, he is, uh,
so much he wants to be so
much in control that he has,
uh, repaired his, his, his burial, uh,
in such a way that it is
almost like a play. Uh,
he wants to be buried where he met
Marcel and not in consecrated ground.
All of these raise the eyebrows of the
church in the town, and I rate her, says,
uh, he has to, he's home a barrier. Uh,
and funeral, it's going to be
like an outdoor Sacramento,
like one of these plays that he wrote and
his body would be the main prop on the
protagonist.
So we see other characteristics
of this character and meanwhile,
uh, Marcella, uh,
appearance on this at the funeral and
delivers a very spirited defense of
herself using very precise forensic
rhetoric that is legal rhetoric and legal
terms to defend herself.
And they issue becomes who
is right at the end. Uh,
the, the, the women characters instead of,
and this are very active and
one to take, uh, uh, destiny,
they're investing in their own hands
and not seller is a, an example.
So one could say Mount Sinai is right
and this is what Don Quixote determines
dokey how to access a
George. And he said, wait,
because when she leaves in
and runs into the hills,
people want to pursue her and
said, oh, no, no, no. He stands,
I will defend her right to be free.
She has a proven beyond any doubt
that she has nothing to do. You had,
you had no culpability
whatsoever in the fate of a,
of [inaudible] and such. You
should be free. So is she right?
Is She right?
Or has Marcella also acted with some
part selfishness by wanting to become a
literary shepherdess to go around the
woods and playing and being a shepherdess,
not marrying these two have
squandered their estates,
have squandered his
possibility? Well, uh, it,
it is not as clear as it would seem.
Uh,
the question I think, uh, remains
open. The sauce, the more has died.
He has killed himself.
Uh,
Marcella has sort of
suffered a civil death,
civil death in the sense that she has
run into the woods, into the hills,
into the thickest part of the
hills, the, uh, uh, the Texas,
and we don't know what's
going to become a of her,
they're separated from society
playing this literary role.
And so, uh, the, I think
that the, the, uh, uh,
the end of, of the, of the episode, uh,
leaves us with a sense of ambiguity.
We have to decide as we did
in the undress episode before,
but it's not as clear as a, as
it seems. It also seems that the,
that the,
the episode is inviting us to,
to consider the effects of literature
that is literature has given Marcella and
also [inaudible] the idea that
absolute freedom is possible.
That you can live your dreams,
that you can live out your desires.
Uh,
and obviously this is a dangerous,
uh,
this is a dangerous proposition which
can lead to the kind of conflict that we
have that we have here.
Uh,
remember the one passing
judgment at the end is a madman.
Don Quixote has passed judgment because
in a way he is like Marcella and he
defends Marcella's right to be,
to be insane like him and to act out his.
Now,
this whole episode in away
concludes on a very hilarious note,
which is the next episode,
the next episode in which
they're going to the wheelchair.
Marcella has escaped and
they find a locals Aminos,
which is a commonplace in literary,
uh, art and literature. Uh, uh,
a very, uh, pleasant place that
he's a with grass, with shade,
with water running, brook waking,
a blessing sound and so forth.
And what do we have?
What happens here?
We have here the translation,
sort of these amorous episode
into, uh, into animal love.
Uh,
when board resy Nunca who doesn't seem
to be a strong enough to harbor such
desires, uh, meets a, uh,
some mayors that are being also,
uh, uh, but there to grace and,
and have water by some,
uh, uh, men from young.
Was this a Galicians?
We said we've met the now people
from various regions in Spain.
And what happens when,
when,
when borders in Anthea approaches
and the mayors to us, the Texas,
we communicate his desires through them.
They meet him with hoops,
they kicked him,
and then there they are.
Keepers come and beat the
daylights out of border.
She Nantais and a, and a don Quixote
on central tried to intervene.
And they are also beaten up by this,
by this, by this people. This is the,
the conclusion in a way of the
resource to mall and Marcella episode.
But in a humorous,
uh,
Keith Serantes likes to work with this
contrasts and with this transposition of
something that was a very serious,
and even sober in the softer one
Marcel episode into, into this, uh,
uh,
a slapstick,
a comedy episode of Poor Rocinante,
uh,
trying,
to seduce the mayor and
being kicked viciously.
So I think that this, the, the
end of, of the, uh, of the, uh,
uh, uh, uh, Marcel angry
software might be sold.
The last comment on it
as it, as it were. Um,
so now the night and he squire themselves
are about to enter into the thick of a
novel,
uh,
which will be a counterpoint between the
Sierra Morina that is this hills into
which they,
they go fleeing from the holy brotherhood.
And also because don't be hurt that wants
to do penance for Lucinia a wilderness
like the wanting,
which Marcella was lost a counterpoint
between that and one Palo Maca is in the,
in where the freakers happened before
with mandatory list and so forth. Uh,
which will become a, a temple, a
courthouse, uh, on where the, the,
the complicated love stories in part one.
And you will see how many complicated
love stories and sue will be resolved in
that, in, and, uh,
so that is what we are going
to move into in the next, uh,
classes.